[Music]
how back does that work
thanks to brilliant org for sponsoring
this episode
hey crazies it's time for another
episode of how the heck does that work
I'm sure many of you have wondered over
the years how does solar power work well
today's your lucky day
to help out with this I've designed a
special clone just for this video
solar powered clone 20% okay maybe we'll
come back to him later first let's get
some lingo out of the way when I say
solar panel you're probably picturing
something like this or maybe even this
but these are called solar arrays
they're collections of solar panels a
single panel or module looks like this
and that panel is made of even smaller
parts called solar cells these cells are
where the solar power comes from
technically speaking though power
sources don't actually provide power
they provide energy in the form of
voltage but we'll get to that later that
reminds me a solar powered glow how are
you doing
30% hmm maybe he could have been
designed a little better anyway let's
get into the structure of one of those
cells they might look like one thing but
there are several layers a metal plate
on the back two different types of
semiconductors a metal grid on the front
an anti-reflection coating in a piece of
glass now that's a lot of layers but
this is all about turning light energy
into electrical energy so let's follow
the light the first layer the light
encounters is glass glass is an
insulator so it's not going to conduct
any noticeable electricity it's also
transparent so most of the light just
passes through the reason it's there is
to keep everything else out the other
layers are kind of fragile so that the
glass protects them next is the anti
reflection layer that's the layer that
makes the solar cell look dark doesn't
that mean the light never gets through
oh oh no it lets the light in it just
doesn't let it back out really how does
that work this coating is so cool
let me explain the semiconductors
underneath are a bit too shiny if they
were exposed over 30 percent of the
light would just reflect away
that simply won't do if we want to use
something like this on the large-scale
power grid we need it to be as efficient
as possible the glass already reflected
away about 5% of the light and we're
going to lose a bunch of it to heating
we can't really afford to lose much more
the anti-reflection coating helps us
hold on to what we've got left and it
works like this you can't just coat it
black otherwise all the light would heat
the cell and you wouldn't get any
electricity this coating has to be
transparent it must let the light pass
through but what happens is you get a
reflection off the top and the bottom if
the coating is just the right thickness
the tube will cancel and the reflected
light disappears leaving only the
incoming light all of it unfortunately
no but but most of it the amount of
cancellation is wavelength dependent but
it's the best we can do
so both the glass and the anti
reflection coating solve some practical
issues but you're not here for practical
issues you probably want to hear how a
solar cell actually generates
electricity
that's where semiconductors come in
terry lee the best one we've got is
silicon right in the middle of the chart
full insulators won't work because the
jump to the conduction band is two bit
conductors won't work because they're
already conductive we want the incoming
light to make it conductive
semiconductors need a boost to become
conductive but only a small a little
visible light will be just enough
there's a slight itty-bitty obstacle for
us though silicon is for from the left
on the periodic table one two three four
that means each silicon atom only has
four electrons in the valence band all
four of which get used up when they bond
to each other in the semiconductor the
incoming light might break some of those
loose but it's not enough solar-powered
clone knows exactly what I mean
65% man I really should have pre
energized him first anyway
pure silicon isn't going to be enough we
need to enhance it using a process
called doping well yeah kind of like
that we are technically injecting
something that doesn't belong to enhance
performance but unlike sports doping
this is totally legal
where was I right enhancements we need
extra electrons that
part of a bond the number of valence
electrons is equal to how many columns
over we are so we just need to step over
one more column to phosphorous that's
for electrons for bonding and one extra
for us to move around
we still want this to be mostly silicon
but if we mix in some phosphorus we get
some spare unbonded electrons to work
with the incoming light can excite those
electrons up to the conduction level but
that's not going to do us any good if we
don't have anywhere for them to go one
step to the left of silicon there are
only three valence electrons that gives
us a hole or opening that our extra
electrons will want to fill
unfortunately the lumen of atoms are a
little too big to fit inside the silicon
so we take one step up to boron instead
they'll fit quite nicely in the silicon
and leave us some electron holes to work
with the two of them together are the
key to how a solar cell works separate
the two types of silicon or neutral
there's no net charge on either one but
the moment the phosphorous doped silicon
touches the boron doped silicon there's
a mad rush of electrons from the
phosphorous to the boron at the boundary
this creates an imbalance of charge
inside the solar cell some of the
phosphorus are now positively charged
because they're missing electrons and
some of the boron are negatively charged
because they have extras any imbalance
of charge will give us an electric field
or more importantly for circuits it will
give us a voltage which is just an
amount of energy per unit charge when
more electrons are ready to move the
voltage tells them which way to go
pretty quickly that initial rush of
electrons forms a barrier between the
two sides they reach an equilibrium and
stop flowing they'll only move again if
we give them the energy to move energy
from incoming light we just need a
couple of conductors to connect the
silicon to a circuit and bam you've got
yourself a solar cell why is the top one
shaped like a grid oh yeah that makes
perfect sense I promise the back
conductor is a full plate but the front
conductor has to leave some space not
enough space and the light can't get
through to the silicon too much space
and the electrons have to travel too far
along the silicon the grid pattern is a
happy medium between the two a happy
little conductor
I'm such a dork so the silicon pair
separates charge and gives us a voltage
but the voltage of an individual solar
cell isn't actually that high it's only
about half a volt for comparison a
double-a battery provides one and a half
volts and a wall socket in the u.s.
provides 120 volts give or take
if we want to use solar cells in the
power grid we need a lot of cells in a
panel and a lot of panels in an array of
course there are other obstacles to
consider to solar cells only provide DC
so we have to convert it to AC but
that's not really a problem with one of
these sunlight can vary from moment to
moment or place the place so we need an
adequate storage device but we have
those they're called batteries and
capacitors why use carbon fuels that
mess up our atmosphere and oceans when
we have a giant nuclear furnace
releasing a seemingly endless supply of
light energy it's a thousand watts of
power for every square meter of Earth we
should be taking advantage so are you
ever gonna look at solar panels the same
way again let us know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
okay I'm ready do it I just finished are
you interested in solar energy then
check out the solar energy course I'm
brilliant org brilliant is a
problem-solving website that teaches you
to think like a scientist
knowing physics as well as I know it
takes more than just watching videos it
takes loads of practice
brilliant gets you to solidify concepts
by giving you fun and challenging
problems they even have hints and
solutions to help out along the way it's
a service you don't really see anywhere
else if you're interested visit
brilliant org slash science asylum and
the first 200 people to sign up will get
20% off an annual premium subscription
it's a really good offer if you want to
strengthen your knowledge tirole Patil
and George Kearney pointed out that my
current was going the wrong way that's
not actually true because I wasn't ever
showing the current I was showing the
direction of electron flow which is
opposite the current Ben Franklin made
everything so complicated anyway I'll
address this in more detail when we get
to circus thanks for watching